es geht um impfen
[Musik]
impfen dazu möchte ich heute mal etwas
sagen worüber wissenschaftler
normalerweise nicht so oft sprechen
deswegen bitte ich euch denn ihr dieses
video schaut dann schaut es bitte auch
bis zum ende nehmen durch die zehn
minuten es ist wirklich wichtig ja man
könnte meinen es gibt nichts was zu
impfen noch nicht gesagt wurde es in
sein leben rettet dass inter nichts mit
autismus zu tun hat dass eben keine
persönliche sondern eine ethische eine
gesellschaftliche entscheidung ist weil
es menschen gibt die aus
gesundheitlichen gründen nicht geimpft
werden können und darauf angewiesen sind
dass wir es tun da blabla
ich weiß leider zu viel über kognitive
verzerrung als dass ich versuchen würde
dieselben argumente immer wieder zu
wiederholen
wenn wir die wissenschaft einen sagte
klar gezeigt hat dann ist es dass wir
menschen immer auf unserer meinung
beharren deswegen will ich heute mal
einen anderen aspekt ansprechen aber
zuerst was uns ein bisschen common
ground schaffen okay ein beängstigendes
argument ist dass uns big pharma alle in
der hand hat und dass die
pharmaindustrie einfach nur weg machen
richtig dass die pharmaindustrie uns
info und unterjubelt damit sie schön
impfstoff verkaufen kann
es ist kein dummes argument die sache
ist nur dieses die pharma wir genauso
viel geld machen würden wenn sie uns der
natur überlassen würden das heißt mit
der behandlung von krankheiten statt mit
der vorbeugen und das nicht nur mit ein
paar spritzen sondern gegebenenfalls mit
jahrelangen behandlungen es sei denn
natürlich impfungen wirken gar nicht
oder noch schlimmer sie machen uns krank
und das ist ich kann sicher sagen
einfach nur bullshit
ich kann ja auch sämtliche quellen
verweisen team wird da dies alles in der
infobox aber wenn ihr nicht glaubt dass
impfen wirksam ist
dann braucht sie dieses video nicht
weiter zuschauen dann kann ich nämlich
nichts sagen was euch auf eurem
confirmation bayerns rausholen wird okay
wir sind uns einig dass impfungen wirken
ja das ist der comic around von dem ich
hier aus gehen muss weil sonst was ich
überhaupt nicht wo ich anfangen sollte
gut man kann er jetzt von der wirkung
von impfungen überzeugt sein aber was
ist mit den nebenwirkungen wie sehen die
risiken tatsächlich aus und genau über
die risiken möchte ich heute ehrlich
sprechen denn da gibt es einige probleme
fangen wir erstmal mit dem berühmtesten
risiko an dass impfungen autismus
hervorrufen geht auf eine gefälschte
studie zurück von and wakefield aus dem
jahre 1998 als herauskam dass diese
studie einfach nur riesen hawks war
wurde sie wenige jahre später
zurückgezogen und seine
zulassung als arzt wurde in frankfurt
auch ziemlich schnell zogen diese
falschen aussagen halten sich so
hartnäckig weil die ursachen für
autismus bis heute nicht geklärt sind
einen anderen fall gab es 2009 in
finnland wo nach einer grippe-impfung 60
kinder und jugendliche an narkolepsie
narkolepsie ist eine seltene krankheit
wo die betroffenen plötzlich von
schlaganfällen übermannt werden
bis heute sind echte kausale
zusammenhänge zwischen narkolepsie und
der impfung immer noch nicht bekannt
wird klar ich auch noch mehr konkrete
beispiel eingeben aber zuerst müssen wir
uns die allgemeine statistik anschauen
so weit wie sie nachvollziehen können
ich weiß ist es ein bisschen trocken
aber statistik ist bei diesem thema
impfen so wichtig bei der risiko
bestimmung von impfstoffen unterscheidet
man zwischen häufigen gelegentlichen von
seltenen nebenwirkungen häufige
nebenwirkungen sind rötungen
schwellungen und schmerzen beim einstich
bereich leichtes fieber seltener auch
übelkeit zu gelegentlich nebenwirkungen
ziel hohes fieber oder fieberkrämpfe bei
der mmr impfung zum beispiel tritt das
in einem von 3000 fällen auch seltene
nebenwirkungen sind zum beispiel schwere
allergische reaktionen die dreht aber
nur in einem von einer millionen fälle
auf doch bei diesen seltenen
nebenwirkungen wird es jetzt echt
schwierig zum beispiel gibt es einen
zusammenhang zwischen der rotavirus
impfung und einer sogenannten into
sektion einer schmerzhaften einstufung
des darms vorläufige daten verweisen
hier auf ein risiko von 1 zu 100000 doch
das gesamtrisiko ist ehrlich gesagt
nicht so leicht einzuschätzen genau
genommen gibt es zwei große probleme
erstens um echte zusammenhänge als
ursache wirkungsbeziehungen feste
stellen müssen gut kontrollierte
randomisierte langzeit studien
durchgeführt werden wenn eine
nebenwirkung in einem von 1000 stellen
auftritt dann kann man das mit
entsprechend großer teilnehmerzahl in
einer studie nachvollziehen denn jetzt
aber eine nebenwirkung in einem von
100.000 fällen auftritt dann fehlt den
wissenschaftern schlicht und einfach die
statistische manpower
man müsste so viele daten erheben wie es
in einer normalen studie kaum möglich
ist stattdessen müsste man daten aus der
bevölkerung sammeln und hier kommen wir
zum zweiten problem nämlich seltene
nebenwirkungen kann man nur feststellen
wenn sie in der anwendung auftreten eben
stoffe unterliegen strengen
regulierungen und kontrollen bis zu der
zulassung ist es ein langer weg aber
selbst nach der zulassung für bleiben
letztlich noch ungewissheiten
um verlässliche rückschlüsse zu ziehen
müsste man weltweite kontrollierte
studien durchführen mit 100000 bis hin
zu millionen von menschen die daten von
so vielen menschen zu sammeln und
sinnvoll aus zu werden ist bereits eine
herausforderung für sich aber eins muss
man sich klar machen bevor ein impfstoff
zugelassen wird kommt man erst recht
nicht an so große daten zusammengefasst
problem eins für seltenere neben der und
braucht man unglaublich viele daten
problem zwei an solche großen
datenmengen kommt man wenn überhaupt
erst nach der zulassung also in der
anwendung und hier kommen wir zu einem
dritten problem und ich laufe gefahr
dass mit diesem video dieses dritte
problem an frühere nämlich die angst der
bevölkerung forschung dauert einfach
lange aber die bevölkerung möchte
natürlich schnelle lösungen beispiel
2007 würde ein neuer impfstoff
eingesetzt ein mrv impfstoff das heißt
eine kombiklasse mumps röteln und
windpocken damit man nicht zweimal
sondern nur einmal die kicks werden
wurden proben fanden forscher heraus
dass sie kommen die impfung bei kleinen
kindern häufiger fieberkrämpfe auslöst
weil es die separaten daraufhin nahm die
impfkommission der usa ihre empfehlung
für diesen kombi wirkstoff wieder zurück
auf dann stellte sich heraus dass die
kombi impfung pro 2300 impfungen gerade
mal ein fieberkrampf mehr auslöst als
die separaten impfungen anderes beispiel
2011 starben in japan vier kinder nach
einer impfung gegen pneumokokken und ein
grippevirus die japanischen behörden
stoppten sofort die beiden impfstoffe
später stellte sich aber heraus dass es
keinen zusammenhang zwischen den
todesfällen und den impfstoffen gehabt
stellt damit nicht sagen dass die
behörden vorstellen gehandelt habe das
haben sie nicht sie haben genau richtig
gehandelt das problem ist dass solche
sehr seltenen vorfälle inzwischen sehr
starke mediale aufmerksamkeit
und die menschen nachvollziehbarer weise
angst bekommen nur wann immer sich
herausstellt dass ein impfstoff doch
nicht so schlimm ist wie befürchtet
kriegt das kein mensch mit die angst und
die skepsis ist das was wir immer bleibt
und weil die forschung bei solchen
seltenen fällen so schwierig ist wie ich
gerade erklärt habe entsteht leichter
eindruck dass wissenschaftler entweder
nicht fähig sind oder schlecht
kontrollierte impfstoffe auf den markt
bringen oder probleme vertuschen
deren lösungen wirklichkeit ganz einfach
sind aber risiken sind natürlich nur
eine seite der medaille man muss immer
risiken gegen wirkungen abwägen wie
immer im leben ich stehe jetzt zum
beispiel auch in den flugzeug obwohl ich
weiß dass fürsorge durch ist mal
abgesehen
aber selbst wenn ich zum beispiel angst
vorm fliegen habe dann bekomme ich mit
jeder erfolgreichen landung das gefühl
geschafft nur beim impfen denkt man ja
nicht geil heute mal wieder keine malern
bekommen sollte man aber vielleicht denn
die abwägung zwischen wirkung und
risiken jetzt sehr schwierig wenn man
ständig von den risiken hört aber nie
von der wirkung die ironie ist die
vorteile sind deswegen nicht sichtbar
weil impfungen ebenso wirksam sind wir
können uns heute gar nicht mehr richtig
vorstellen unter masern oder polen
der erfolg der impfungen tritt sich also
selbst in den hintern anstatt angst vor
ernsten krankheiten zu haben wie wir
heute dann impfungen zu glück nicht mehr
sehen bekommen wir angst vor viel
selteneren nebenwirkungen nur weil die
immer in den medien auftauchen
und weil wissenschaftler ernsthafte
probleme damit haben solchen selteneren
nebenwirkungen nachzugehen
fühlt man sich als sorgende mutter
schnell im stich gelassen denn erstmal
eine sorge besteht dann gibt es für
wissenschaftler und behörden fast keinen
guten weg mehr um da wieder rauszukommen
nehmen wir das beispiel tiere mehr saal
ein quecksilberhaltige
konservierungsmittel dass bei ihm fuhren
eingesetzt wird suzuki meter laufs es
ist kein reines wechsel
es ist eine quiksilver verbindung die
weniger gefährlich ist als reines
quecksilber und für die mengen in denen
es zugelassen ist besteht auch kein
risiko verdacht aber trotzdem gibt es
inzwischen kilometer
freie impfstoffe auf die jeder
zurückgreifen kann der sich damit nicht
wohl fühlt und jetzt fragen die leute
natürlich wenn das angeblich nicht so
schlimm ist warum hat man das jetzt raus
genommen hätte mainz aber keine
alternative geboten würden andere jetzt
wieder sagen die pharmaindustrie will
uns mit quecksilber vergiften die harte
wahrheit ist wenn ihr hundertprozentige
sicherheit bei impfstoffen haben wollt
dann werdet ihr sie niemals haben
eine hundertprozentige sicherheit geht
es niemals gegen all die probleme die
ich heute aufgezählt habe sind probleme
der datenerhebung die nur bei sehr
seltenen nebenwirkungen auftreten
deshalb habe ich persönlich keine angst
vorm impfen weil ich weiß dass die
risiken im vergleich zu den wirkungen
verschwindend gering sind so trocken
statistik ist die statistik ist wirklich
essentiell wichtig um impfen richtig zu
verstehen zum beispiel ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit 100.000 kleiner als
die wahrscheinlichkeit in deutschland in
einem verkehrsunfall zu sterben die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines zu eine million
ist kleiner als die wahrscheinlichkeit
ein sechser im lotto zu gewinnen bevor
es impfung gab musste jede mutter jeder
vater angst haben dass ihr kind an polio
erkrankt diphtherie stirbt manchmal
sogar an masern das ist es wofür wir
angst haben müssten und wie gesagt
impfen ist keine persönliche
entscheidung etwas das man mit sich
selbst ausmachen kann und selbst die
konsequenzen tragen kann nein
mit jeder impfung die ein gesunder
mensch ablehnt gefährden wir das leben
von vor allem babys und kindern deren
immunsystem zu schwach ist um geimpft zu
werden wenn ihr gutes tun wollt dann
teilt dieses video und schreibt mir was
ihr denkt schön schlau
vielen dank dass ihr dieses video bis
zum ende geschaut hat es war wirklich
ein bisschen lang und anstrengend aber
dafür sehr wichtig schreibt mir wie
gesagt eure kommentare
steinbrück sichern